hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
top 5 meine minecraft mini games spiele
die ich am besten finden in minecraft
und ich möchte eigentlich gar nicht
lange vorher darum umlagern wir fangen
direkt an mit platz nummer fünf platz
nummer 5 sind die guten alten survival
games in diesem spielmodus falls sie ihn
nicht eigentlich schon alle längst
kennen solltet geht es darum dass
mehrere spieler das können teilweise
zehn spieler sein das kann aber auch
über 100 spieler seien im kreis borken
und in der mitte sind ganz viele items
in kisten riese gilt es sich zu
schnappen und danach irgendwie sich gut
auszurüsten und dann alle alle hätten
alle anderen mitspieler nacheinander
abzuschlachten bis irgendwann kurz vorm
ende irgendwie dann angezeigt wird ja
jetzt findet das set match statt wo man
mit den letzten übrig gebliebenen
spielern zusammen einen raum
teleportiert wird und da sich noch mal
schön die klappe die köpfe einhauen kann
ich die klappe das ganze ist so mit
dieser erste richtige online spielmodus
der je gemacht wurde in minecraft das
ist richtig cool ich glaube das ganze
entstand sogar durch bereit sein name
ist jedenfalls ist das mein platz fünf
und jetzt kommt's platz vier
platz nummer 4 ist also auf deutsch eine
im lauf das ist ein spielmodus den es
schon in call of duty ganz damals gab
uns war hatte man bei call of duty eine
handfeuerwaffe mit einer theorie habe
außerdem ein mikro geschlagen eine
handfeuerwaffe mit nur einer patrone
drin und man konnte dann einmal schießen
und dann hat man quasi nur einen schuss
und aber nicht getroffen hat ist man
quasi auf das messer angewiesen musste
zu dem anderen hin laufen müsste ihn
abstechen mit dem messer oder man hat er
getroffen bekommt dann noch eine patrone
also irgendwie das ist quasi für jedes
jedes töten eines spielers bekommt man
eine patrone und ja das ganze gibt es in
minecraft und zwar mit einem bogen und
einem pfeil das heißt man hat dann quasi
sind ein fall und wenn man trifft kriegt
man noch einen fall und wenn man halt
nicht schriftlich sondern auch das
messer angewiesen und wenn man mit dem
messer jemanden tötet und man hatte noch
einen fall dann hat man zwei pfeile und
das ist wohl eine clever und das ist
mein platz nummer vier
platz nummer drei ist das gute alte hide
and seek was ich von hifi von dem hof im
server kenne was darauf aber total kacke
ist weil der hfm server kacke ist und
das ist einfach mal
meinung der hfm server ich finde ihn
einfach nicht gut im glück gibt es aber
block hand auf mein plex was sogar viel
cooler als ich fast hätte ich [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay ich packe ich übrigens auch die
ganzen spielmodi und in die beschreibung
mit der server ip et cetera dann könnt
ihr da einfach mal selber drauf spielen
und zwar blockern einfach dass man sich
entweder als haider als einen blog
verkleideter so haider der typ der sich
versteckt man kann sich dann block
aussuchen natürlich nicht so was wie
erde oder stein oder irgendwie sowas es
einfach überall auf der welt gibt
sondern mehr so was wie beispielsweise
ein zuckerrohr in den tee einen kuchen
ein crafting table oder auch ein tier
und das sind andi haider und dann gibt
es auch noch die sica wo es auch
verschiedene arten gibt da gibt es
beispielsweise die tage ca die
beispielsweise dann einfach ich sage
immer wieder beispielsweise
beispielsweise sondern einfach schauen
können wo in welcher nähe sich gerade
der nächste haider befindet oder die
bombe bombastischer heißen die glaube
ich die irgendwie tnt fallen lassen
können
und da gibt es ganz ganz viele klassen
und die haben die aufgabe in einer
bestimmten zeit die ganzen seeker
allianzen haider zu finden und diese zu
zerstören und wenn sie das nicht
schaffen wir mal die haider geworden und
wenn sie schafft dann haben die sika
gewonnen und wenn ein haider stirbt dann
wird er automatisch zum sieg und wenn
ein sieger steht er auch wieder als
sieger und das ist blogger
beziehungsweise einen sieg und platz
nummer drei platz nummer zwei ist bett
wars auf dem gocher hd server und zwar
geht es beim etwas darum dass man
einfach ganz viele items bekommt also
ganz viel bronze beziehungsweise kupfer
bzw
was ist das eigentlich genau man bekommt
auf jeden fall so braunisch eisblock und
die kamera eintauschen gegen rüstung
gegen blöcke et cetera dann bekommt man
auch noch silberne blöcke also reisen
die man eintauschen kann gegen etwas
wertvolleres blöcke wie beispielsweise
ein schwert und eine kiste und in der
mitte gibt es gold und in der mitte die
gehörte sich zu behaupten diese mitte
der map und zwar gibt es da gold mit dem
gold kann man sich die wertvollsten
sachen kaufen beispielsweise und bogen
oder tnt oder ender perlen et cetera die
man dann dafür gebrauchen kann um zu den
anderen inseln der gegnern zu fliegen
mit der einer perle beziehungsweise
einfach irgendwie sich hin zu bauen mit
blöcken und sich dadurch zu prügeln mit
schwertern und pfeil und bogen und
einfach vom gegner das bett zu zerstören
so dass der gegnerische spieler nicht
mehr respawnen kann und dementsprechend
dann
das ist der sinn von betsson das ist
mein platz nummer zwei platz nummer eins
ist super smash mops wer hätte es nicht
gedacht und zwar es ist mein absoluter
lieblingsmodell das habe ich schon sehr
sehr oft gesagt es ist ein modus linie
wie die anderen modi jetzt auch einfach
ergebnisse und zwar ist das angelehnt an
smash für die iju und wii und nintendo
konsolen usw wo man sich eine person
aussuchen kann was mensch ist das
beispielsweise an picacho nehmen man
kann den man kann den den blablabla ganz
viele verschiedene browser et cetera
und da ist es halt so man kann sich
verschiedene mops nehmen wie
beispielsweise ein ritter skelett
welches ein image erzeugen kann und ein
ritter skull senden kann oder
beispielsweise ein skelett welches eine
bahn attacke machen kann also eine
knochen attacke oder beispielsweise
einen bogenschuss schnellschuss und es
gilt den anderen spieler beziehungsweise
die mitspieler beziehungsweise die
gegner von dieser insel runter zu kicken
und wer als erstes 4 bis was weiß ich
wie oft mal runter gekickt wurde hat das
spiel verloren und man hat er quasi
einerseits diese funktion dass man
einfach andere unterschlagen kann
andererseits hat jede klasse aus eine
special tags was ich auch gar schon
gesagt hat so freuen und das wars mit
meinen top 5 mini games in minecraft es
euch gefallen da würde ich mich
definitiv über eine bewertung freuen und
dann sehen wir uns im nächsten video
wieder